MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
With this lecture,
I'd like to introduce
the major players of this
class, the particles,
fundamental particles, but also
some of the compound particles,
which play a role in
the discussions we'll
have over the next weeks.
For centuries, people
believed that atoms
are the most fundamental
constituents of matter.
The name atom comes
from the Greek atomic,
which means not divisible.
But as you know today, electrons
and nuclei build an atom.
But even those nuclei are
not fundamental particles.
As you see nicely
here in this picture,
the nucleus can be built out
of many neutrons and protons,
and even those
protons and neutrons
are not fundamental particles.
A proton, for example,
as depicted here,
has three components
and three constituents,
two up quarks and
one down quark.
A neutron, then, is built out
of one down quark and two up
quarks.
It's kind of important to
understand and appreciate
the size of those particles,
specifically the difference
in size.
Comparing here an atom, a
typical atom, of the size of 10
to the minus 10 meters,
and that compares
to a nucleon, which can be a
few 10 to the minus 15 meters.
When we talk about a
proton, we typically
like to use units
of femtometers,
which is 10 times 10
to the minus 15 meters.
The tremendous size different
or the expansive finding
of the famous gold
foil experiment, which
found that an atom
basically is made out
of a nothingness, empty
space, and a very dense
charged core, the nucleus.
So you see this very
much in this picture
and by comparing those
order of magnitudes.
Not shown in this picture
here is a particle which
doesn't really like to interact
with anybody else or which
the forces it's interacting with
are so weak that it cannot be
found, and that is a neutrino.
A neutrino is not that
different from an electron
or from a quark.
It's just that the
interactions it participates in
are only the big force
as we understand today.
Just to be clear, when I talk
about a fundamental particle,
I talk about a particle
which has no size,
it's infinitely small.
It has no substructure,
meaning it cannot be broken up
into constituents and
can also not be excited.
Having said that, this is our
current understanding of nature
and of those particles.
Experimentally, we can
only probe those particles
to a certain scale
or size, and we'll
talk later about how
precisely we actually
do know that a
quark is fundamental
or an electron is fundamental.
In this discussion here
and most of the lecture,
I talk about the standard
model in particle physics.
It is a fact that
our measurements
and our experimental
findings are
in fantastic agreement with
this very predictive theory.
The only experimental
deviation from this
is the fact that we measure
the mass of neutrinos
to be non-zero.
As a consequence, you could say
the standard model is broken
or we found physics
beyond the standard model,
but it is actually
rather straightforward
to extend the standard model
to accommodate neutrino masses.
So we can just forget
about this small fact
and assume that the standard
model describes nature
as we know it.
In the last week of this class,
we'll talk about motivation,
why we thinks that the
standard model, in fact,
is not complete, and one of the
big drivers here is the fact
that we cannot describe
all observations in nature,
specifically the
observation of dark matter,
with the standard model
in particle physics.
But that's for a later date.
Looking into some more
detail, the standard model
has sets of particles,
some particles which
carry forces and some
are metaparticles.
The ones who carry forces
are all spin-one particles,
and their bosons.
We have, in the standard model,
describe three interactions.
The electromagnetic
interactions,
which are known from light,
electromagnetic phenomena,
chemistry.
The atom's behavior
molecule is determined
by electromagnetic interactions.
And then there's a
strong interaction.
The name already tells
you that it's strong.
It's very strong.
The first carrier
here is the gluon.
The gluons, there's
eight, and then
differentiated by
the so-called color,
which is an interesting effect.
And then, there is the
weak interaction carried
by the W boson and the Z boson.
They are different in their own
right because they carry mass.
They are massive particles.
And they're actually quite
heavy, about 80 to 100 times as
heavy as a proton.
The weak interaction is
responsible for neutron decays,
also responsible for
the burning of the sun.
And in our nuclear physics part,
we talk in detail about what
that all means.
Gravitational effects
are not considered
in the standard model.
They are very,
very weak compared
to the strength of the other
forces we'll discuss here.
But it's technically
very difficult
to actually accommodate
gravity as part
of a quantum [INAUDIBLE] theory.
And therefore, we will
simply ignore this fact.
And this is yet
another reason why
you can consider
the standard model
to be incomplete as a model
or theory describing nature.
The matter particles
themselves are all fermions.
They have spin half.
And they come in three
different generations.
The only difference between
one generation to the next
is the fact that those
particles have different mass.
In other words, their
coupling to the Higgs field
is different.
And that's the only difference
between those particles.
There's consequences
out of this, for example
heavier particles indicating
to lighter particles.
We differentiate between
the quarks and leptons.
Quarks partake in the
strong interactions,
while electrons are neutral
in the strong interaction.
And then we have seen
neutrinos already
and, electron-type particles.
Electron-type particles,
charged leptons,
they have electric charge.
So they couple to photons
by neutrinos bond.
I'll show you here again one
of those striking differences.
An electron is 9 times 10 to
the minus 31 kilograms heavy.
We like to talk about
units in a different class.
But that's 511 keV.
While the neuron is about 200
times heavier, and even heavier
the tau lepton.
And as I said
before, that allows
that tau lepton [INAUDIBLE]
neurons to decay
into lighter particles.
We'll talk about this and how
we can use those decays in order
to learn about the
standard model.
And then there is
the Higgs boson.
And again, the Higgs
boson, discovered in 2012,
plays a very special role
in the standard model.
We talk about the
Lagrange is a theory which
describes the standard model,
or which is the basic--
is a theory itself.
And later on, in this theory
we introduce a potential which
is shown here-- it's
this Mexican hat--
if you want-- potential.
And what you see here
is that in this picture,
that the lowest energy
state of this potential
breaks a symmetry.
So it's away from the 0 point.
And that symmetry
breaking then gives mass
to the W and the Z boson,
which I was describing before.
And the coupling of meta
particles to the Higgs field
gives mass at this point.
All this on a later date.
I thought here, I'd also
give you how CERN actually
depicts the Higgs boson.
July 4th is a special
day in the US,
but it's also a
special day at CERN,
because the Higgs discovery
has been announced on this day.
And at CERN, typically, the
menu is enriched on that day
by the Higgs boson itself
in the form of pizza, which
takes the shape of
event displays--
displays of
proton-proton collisions
into the Higgs boson
and then further decays.
We'll look at some of those
event displays also later.
Well, that completes the
elementary-- the fundamental
particles of the standard
model, particles which describe
almost everything around us.
So we have seen the charged
and neutral leptons.
We have seen the quarks.
We have seen the force carriers,
with the W/Z bosons, the photon
and the gluon, and
the Higgs boson, which
is kind of the very special
particle holding this
all together.
An interesting point
here is, again,
looking a little bit at history
and when those particles have
been discovered, and also
when those particles have
been explained--
and I don't want to
read this all to you.
You see that the earliest
discovery was a discovery
by J.J. Thomson of the
electron, and the latest,
the completion of the particles
in the standard model--
the Higgs boson-- in 2012.
Interesting for the
Higgs boson, the time
between the
theoretical discovery
by Peter Higgs and
friends was about 50 years
before the
experimental discovery.
But then there is also
composite particles.
The things around you are
all composite particles.
Here, we can differentiate
between mesons and baryons.
Mesons are particles
which are made out
of quarks and antiquark pairs
[? for the ?] bound states.
And they are bosonic, because
you add 2 1/2 particles
together.
One example is a pion,
which is made out
of up quarks and
down quarks that can
be charged in neutral pions.
And the zoo of particle
increases quite quickly
if you then consider that it's
not just up and down quarks
making those particles.
But you could add strangeness to
that, meaning a strange quark.
And so you see here in this
picture, the mesons, the pions,
etas, but also then neutrons
and charged particles
with different charges,
and then kaons,
which are particles
which have one
s quark in addition to an
up quark and down quark.
And then there's baryons.
They are made out
of three quarks.
We have already seen the
protons and neutrons.
But also here, you can see
a different configuration.
We'll introduce the
concept of isospin.
You can see here the
proton and the neutron,
and then strangeness being
added with one or two
components of strangeness.
And then there is this
isospin component as well.
This situation becomes
complex very, very quickly.
But we'll look at
this in more detail.
And then again,
putting those bound
states together-- bound
states of protons and neutrons
through the strong
force gives us
a rich table of nuclei
on isotope tape.
Here, you can describe nuclei
by the number of protons, which
is typically called Z, and
the number of neutrons,
which is typically
called N. The sum,
N plus Z is the atomic mass.
Now, each proton and neutron
are about 1 geV heavy.
And then the atomic mass
is simply the sum of them.
So you already know
explicitly how heavy
your isotope might be.
We'll talk about the fact
that those masses are not
quite the sum of
the masses later,
because there is some
binding energy involved.
And then isotopes can
be stable or unstable.
They can decay in
various processes.
You can combine them.
It's very interesting to
understand how they're actually
being created in our solar
system or the universe
in general.
So with this, I would
like to conclude
this part of the introduction.
So we have seen
the major players
of this course with the
fundamental particles,
but also the compound particles,
meson, baryons, and nuclei.
And there's a few more
points in the introduction
before we then dive
into a little bit more
of the theoretical discussion.